(acclamations)
- Toujours à ses côtés,
et toujours avec un léger pas
en arrière, Camilla, désormais
reine consort des Britanniques,
semble s'effacer en public,
pour laisser toute la place
à Charles.
Camilla Rosemary Shand,
née en 1947 d'une mère
aristocrate et d'un père
militaire, a lgtgtemps eu
le mauvais rôle.
Celui d'une briseuse de couple.
En 1995, dans une entrevue-choc
très critiquée de la BBC,
Lady Diana disait qu'il y avait
trois personnes dans son mariage
avec le prince Charles,
en référence à sa liaison
avec Camilla, elle-même mariée.
MICHAEL BINYON,
éditorialiste, "The Times"
- Elle était dans une position
très difficile, surtout parce
que la presse a toujours dit
des choses mauvaises sur elle.
Elle est une maîtresse, elle est
vraiment quelque chose que...
une femme qui a... qui v volé
son époux.
- C'est en97970 que Camilla
et Charles se seraient connus.
Leur idylle aura duré trois ans.
Puis, Charles a rejoint
la Marine royale.
En 1973, Camilla épouse un
militaire, Andrew Parker Bowles,
avec qui elle a deux enfants :
Thomas et Laura.
En 1981, le mariage de Charles
et de Diana Spencer a toutes
les allures d'un conte de fée,
mais ce n'est qu'une façade.
Rapidement, la relation
du prince de Galles avec Camilla
Parker Bowles reprend, faisa
les choux gras des tabloïds.
Camilla divroce en 1995.
Et la fin tragique de Diana,
la princesse des coeurs,
en 1997, la condamne
au purgatoire.
- Quand on est fan de Diana
à l'époque, c'était difficile
d'être fan de Camilla en même
temps.
ANNE-ELISABETH MOUTET,
éditorialiste et écrivaine
- Il a fallu beaucoup de temps
pour qu'on l'accepte, d'abord
parce que les Britanniques
aiment beaucoup la princesse
Diana, et ensuite parce que même
dans un pays où peu de gens vont
dans les églises, ils n'aiment
pas l'adultère.
- Pour faire oublier 20 années
de liaison secrète, il fallait
restaurer l'image et
la réputation de Camilla.
Ses apparitions aux côtés
du Prince Charles ont été
limitées et elle s'est impliquée
dans des oeuvres caritatives.
- Tous les gens i i la
rencontrent dans les différentes
fonctions qu'elle a exercées,
les visites qu'elle a faites,
les visites officielles,
se rendent compte qu'elle est
assez simple.
- Dans les années 2000,
les fils de Charles et de Diana
l'l'acceptent. Elle gagne même a
confiance de la reine Élisabeth.
- Peu à peu, la reine a accepté
Camilla. Et pas simplement
accepté. Mais il semble qu'elles
étaient de bonnes amies.
Elles étaient toujours ensemble.
La reine a montré sa confiance
en elle.
(applaudissements)
- Forte de cet appui,
Camilla exhibe devant la psssse
sa bague de fiançailles.
Le couple convole en secondes
noces en 2005. Elle devient
Duchesse de Cornouailles,
mais son statut de reine consort
est incertain.
Il a fallu attendre le jubilé
de platine de la reine Élisabeth
pour qu'iln n soit ainsi.
Le roi Charles III la confirme
dans son titre.
Ils vont désormais s'unir pour
servir la couronne d'Angleterre.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa